let's talk about the dick towels and
then you give them one of these boom oh
that is big that's a big monster dick I
can't remember how the dick towel thing
in particular I remember okay yeah my
mother came out to visit my two mothers
and uh we were living
um not how I expected that store to
start but yeah yeah we were down in
Venice Beach and you know when you walk
along Venice Beach they have those
stores with funny t-shirts
right yeah Venice boardwalk's got tons
of that so I just always remember seeing
those ridiculous ones with the bikinis
and I don't always be like who thinks
that's funny like who would ever buy
that and so both my mothers come out and
and I'm back at the house and they come
back from the beach and they're both
wearing them and they're like and
they're like look at these this is
hilarious it's a big T-shirt with the
bikini with the bikini ladies with the
large breasts and my mom would be like
look I got big tits I'm like yep that's
it